hello everyone and welcome back to
versus I'm your host Mark Ellis and this
is the show where we take the finest of
art the most legendary of artiste and
today the sharpest Clause of comic book
War and celebrate them by engaging in
Mortal Kombat and for a couple Heroes
who march to their own or to their
people's Own Drum I don't think combat
is going to be a problem finally after
years of waiting we get to see Black
Panther and Wolverine tussle on the big
screen if you're watching this episode
on a big screen it might actually happen
someday at the movies who knows but for
now we're taking a look back at the film
careers of t'challa and Logan Howlett
how they got their start how much coin
and critical praise they generated and
who really is the best at what they do
you don't have to do this
all right maybe you do it's hard to
argue with either for many reasons one
they're fictional but also they start in
their own impressive line of franchise
films forging a legacy that is still
going strong in one form or another to
this very day and Beyond in one corner
we have Wolverine he also goes by the
name Logan he's played by Hugh Jackman
has a short temper and really lives for
that moment when he gets to flex his
claws
[Applause]
Panther and in the movie Black Panther
he was inhabited by t'challa played by
the late great Chadwick Boseman he's got
a patient demeanor but really lives for
that moment when there finally is going
to be peace in his home country of
wakanda
all right so maybe Logan wakes up mad
and ready to Duke it out more so than to
chawa but t'challa's ready to play ball
and when it's time for black panther to
take matters into his own hands the
Kitty's Got Claws here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score round three iconic moments round
four Legacy and then we'll do a Wild
Card round a term that is fitting based
on the animals that these two Dynamic
superheroes represent Wolverine first
appeared on the big screen in the year
2000's X-Men and was in immediate scene
stealer it also made a star of Hugh
Jackman black panther as a cat of prey
might waited patiently to strike until
2016's Captain America Civil War and we
would have never saw it coming except
you know marketing the movie and whatnot
Chadwick Boseman was already an
established Star by the time he took on
the legend of the Panther and that
announcement was quickly lauded for the
MCU Landing an actor of that caliber
both Jackman and Bozeman would go on to
reach icon status with these particular
roles in addition to their larger body
of tremendous work but today it's all
about the films based on the talking
picture books as black panther is about
to dance with Wolverine under the pale
Moonlight enough said bub you just call
me
blob
no let's get it on round one box office
of all the reasons these two are
headlining a matchup on versus the show
that People magazine says quote exists
we get it Mark please stop calling us
one of the biggest in the eyes of bean
counters in those fancy Studio offices
is it a film starring black panther or
Wolverine is destined to make what is
officially deemed a crap ton of Moolah
comic book movies are big business now
but it wasn't always that way sure you'd
have a celebrated moment in time like
with 1978 Superman or Batman from 1989
but it wasn't until the dawn of this
Millennium that folks realized that a
lot of us really love this stuff and now
we have the technology and the interest
to step up to the next level along with
blade and Spider-Man X-Men hitting in
the year 2000 would contribute to a
seismic shift in studio tent pull
release dates Wolverine Silver Screen
debut was a massive hit chugging along
to almost 300 million dollars X2 topped
out at over 400 million bucks in 2003
and then the last stand closed out the
trilogy on a high-ish note at least in
terms of coin with 459 million dollars
okay so Scrooge mcduck's bald is already
swimmable with over a billion dollars
from the first three mutant movies but
Wolfie was still feeling frisky he's the
most popular character in that whole
realm so why not spin off some solo
albums it worked for Phil Collins and
Peter Gabriel Logan had his Genesis
revealed in 2009's X-Men Origins
Wolverine and a cartoon clawed its way
somehow to 374 million dollars and no I
cannot get over how bad the claws look
in that movie
oh
shiny he pops them out I expect Bob
Hoskins and Roger Rabbit to LEAP an
attack at any minute The Wolverine did
Rebound in 2013. I watched it again last
night when it was in theaters 416
million dollars gross then X-Men Days of
Future Past set the high bar for the
entire franchise at almost 750 million
dollars in 2014. Logan closed out Hugh
Jackman's run we thought in 2019 raking
in 614 million dollars to keep him cozy
in a fancy retirement home not okay well
we were all meeting these X-Men for the
first time in 2000 black panther had the
luxury of joining well-known Avengers
like Captain America and Iron Man for
the 2016 melee that was Civil War on its
way to uh are you sitting down 1.1
billion dollar haul sure we were excited
to see our established hero scrimmage
and also look it's a new Spider-Man but
black panther was part of the fire that
made that ticket so hot and the
post-credits scene of that film it's all
about out teasing his solo project which
was accurately titled Black Panther and
released in 2018. hmm oh right that
movie demolished even harder at the box
office notching 1.3 billion dollars with
a release date in February the film
became an immediate cultural Touchstone
as Chadwick Boseman was playing the
first black superhero to lead a film in
the MCU over 15 years after we first saw
Wesley Snipes in Marvel's Blade trilogy
black panther wakanda forever has plenty
of Buzz around it for different reasons
it's slated to close out phase four of
this Cinematic Universe phase 3 was
highlighted by the 1-2 punch of Avengers
Infinity war and end game and in a story
we're just now breaking here those
movies made a lot of dough like almost 5
billion dollars combined for just two
movies an end game is constantly
wrestling with avatar for the crown of
the highest grossing film ever and the
leader is currently whichever one just
had a re-release in theaters where it
was probably the number one movie that
weekend but here's where we also get
into tricky territory I give Black
Panther full credit for being a major
player in Civil War K is closed but for
Infinity war and end game dude has a
total of less than 5 minutes of screen
time it's memorable all right but so are
Hugh Jackman's cameos in both X-Men
apocalypse and first class more so first
class than apocalypse but still you get
the point I didn't include those films
in Wolverines total so it'd be unfair to
give black panther total credit for that
5 billion dollars you all do realize
Star Wars sold for 4.2 billion right
like the entire galaxy cost that much
anywhoof we did count all four of those
MCU flicks the child would be sitting on
a throne of 7.3 billion dollars
Wolverine's been in over double the
amount of movies yet only has 3.3
billion bucks to his name so even if we
shave off say four billion dollars of
black panthers total he's still tied
with rodent man a wolverine is
technically a rodent we know that right
it's not a wolf so let's take a look at
the wall of averages it's not good for
Wolfenstein I mean he's got 474 million
dollars per movie and that's great but
black panther has had 1.2 billion
dollars per featured outing Wolverine's
has been flexing on the big screen for
significantly longer and that could help
him in the coming rounds but for right
now black panther has just hauled in too
much cheddar for a debate he wins round
one and takes the lead one to nothing
you might want to pick up the pitch
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score for all of you who are yelling at
me either through your TV or your
streaming device or the one person I can
hear angrily stopping one four above
this studio can I just explain that
money talks okay much more than either
one of these characters does as a matter
of fact they're bigger on actions and
symbols than word salads but you know
who does love verbs and nouns and
gerunds so much so they sometimes get
paid by them critics oh yeah they have
plenty to say about both Legends live
action flicks and all those opinions get
factored into the Tomato Meter why but
fret not use Stompers of Earth I really
think they're wearing cowboy boots
upstairs there might be an actual horse
on that fork it doesn't matter what mode
of transportation you took to the movie
theater it could have been a horse a car
legs if you saw a movie you can also
have your take added to the mix with a
verified audience score and judging from
how many movies we're honoring here
today
um y'all really like these two like a
lot Sally Field Oscar speech level
affection fun fact black panther tough
to beat that's not up for debate but did
you know he's never starred in a film
that's under 90 on the Tomato Meter sure
Infinity Wars at 85 percent but he's in
it for less than three minutes and 85
percent by the way still good enough to
get you into most any college you want
to go to kids the high bar for black
panther is the movie of the same name
and it rests at 96 percent stunningly
that movie also represents the low bar
for his audience score which is again
still good but only at 79 Captain
America Civil War is more evenly
dispersed with a 90 Tomato Meter
complimented by an 89 audience score
Wolverine as inhabited by Hugh Jackman
and only Hugh thus far makes a strong
Contender against the panther in this
round as he has two films that are in
the 90s on the TM you want to guess
three say okay I can't wait any longer
it's is a future past starring him and
his took us at 90 percent and then Logan
shimmied past that standard for a 94
both those films are also pure with the
audience logging in 90 for Logan and a
91 for days of future past but the risk
that comes with bringing as many movies
to the table as a wolverine does is it
eventually there's got to be a dud in
there somewhere right well Ryan
reynolds's Deadpool would be happy to
tell you about it you know when his
mouth isn't sewed shut in Wolverine
Origins
I don't want to say that title again
it's exhausting and I don't really like
it because the movie Stacks up at just
38 on the Tomato Meter and it can't even
get to fresh with the audience following
just shy at 58 X-Men properly kicked the
initial Trilogy off in Grand fashion
hitting 82 percent on the Tomato Meter
followed by x2s 85 percent and the Last
Dance 57 which all things considered it
should be thankful for luckily the
Wolverine fared better at 71 percent
setting the stage for Logan and the R
rating that some hope would accompany
The Wolverine and it's tough to tell if
the two movies that Hugh Jackman makes a
quick stop in would even help him in
this round first class starring him for
all of 15 seconds and two words and
seven letters it's 86 which is good but
apocalypse is 47 and to be honest what
the hell was that scene he was in anyway
go [ __ ] yourself I mean I guess if my
body looked that good I'd find any
excuse to be in a movie shirtless but
come on we get it I hope that's the last
question of that guy t'challa is Far
West vain he's never selfish so I'll ask
him if we may consider and game in
Infinity war end games at 94 and really
the bottom line is this folks love these
two characters so what's the more
spectacular Tomato Meter achievement a
20-year career with only two real
stumbles or a damn near perfect record
with grades so high you'd be applying
for a scholarship at Oxford University
let's take a look at the averages done
by a fella who definitely didn't get
into college on the strength of his
mathematical ability Hugh Jackman as
wolver Odin is rocks solid fresh it's 74
for his per film average That's not
including his fun cameo in Night of the
Museum 3 where he played himself and he
tries to summon the Wolverine claws
while on stage in a play I really like
that movie it makes me cry ask me about
it later thanks buddy
he recognized you yeah that was awesome
meanwhile Chadwick Boseman is Black
Panther is Super Fresh averaging 91 for
all his appearances within 87 for the
audience score Jackman's audience
averages 77 but here's the thing while I
can't argue with the top dogs at Studios
it's hard to not see the body of work as
being a major factor in this Tomato
Meter round maybe it's because I've held
this perch at versus for what Four
Seasons 20 Seasons It's All Aboard but
in that time it's become apparent that
the more at-bats you have the more
likely it is that you'll strike out the
tragic component to this equation is
that we'll never get to see how far
Bozeman would have wanted his ride as
black panther to last but we do know
that the mythology the mantle getting
passed through the generations is going
to serve him well in remembrance in
Black Panther wakanda forever Wolverine
will someday be recast although
according to recent vids trending on
Twitter that might not happen as soon as
we all thought overall looking at their
entire filmography Chadwick Boseman does
have the higher Tomato Meter single film
over Hugh Jackman with 97 percent for
2020's ma rainey's black bottom Hugh
Jackman has twin 94 for Logan and bad
education as his all-time best efforts
black panthers off to a great start as
the property forges a groundbreaking
cinematic Legacy but Wolverine has been
the focal point of the X-Men for two
decades and it ain't stopping just yet
his multiple fresh efforts are the
slightly more impressive feat in my eyes
and thus he wins the round tying the
score at one to one
thank you round three iconic moments and
here's where the fun begins math can be
enjoyable as I so definitely taught
everyone in the last two rounds but now
algebra class is out let's have recess
where we get to run outside and attempt
to act out our favorite moments from two
of the best characters the comics have
ever shuttled onto the big screen but
let the professionals attempt the stunts
both characters have a strong case to
make right out of the gate the first
time we meet t'challa we quickly see his
heroism and athletic ability in Civil
War he's got a grapple with a changing
world and takes sides plus that first
chase scene is so cool look at how fast
he is and black panther is also an
integral part of the world famous
airport brawl where the best MCU Heroes
duked it out over political differences
while Thor and Hulk had a beer at a far
away Realm
I'm glad I don't care it was an exciting
moment for all comic book shop regulars
like me way back in the year 2000 when
The Uncanny X-Men were finally gonna be
in a big time movie and it did not
disappoint it was awesome to see Cyclops
and storm and Gene and Professor X and
Magneto but if Wolverine was bad it'd be
like brushing your teeth with no
Listerine and the toothbrush the hotel
gives you for free weak bristles no good
but the film opens with a cage fight in
a rural bar Rogue sees our wolfy in
action and then he gets to tussle with
saber tooth a Lambo field okay wasn't
actually there but it felt like a snowy
playoff game between two arch Rivals it
was good stuff Wolverine steals
motorcycles plays by his own rules and
Ruffles feathers but we also see his
emotional capacity when Rogue has her
um setback then in X2 he is the star
Quiet Moments Like chugging Dr Pepper
with Iceman quickly lead to a
rage-fueled rampage as he defends the
school against intruding military Powers
The Last Stand was a little lean on
memorable sequences but the climax
featuring him doing what is necessary
and summoning all of his might
encouraged to pull it off despite his
feelings for Gene still resonates and
look I'm a sucker for watching Heroes
practice so I love the opening of The
Last Stand where it's the danger room
tossing them a virtual scenario cigars
get lit stuff explodes I'm shoving
popcorn in my face it was fun class
dismissed I do remember getting mad at
X-Men Origins for a couple reasons a the
movie wasn't good B the claws looked
like a cool world outtake and see it was
disappointing because the opening 10
minutes of that movie are fire
Deadpool's there Sabertooth and Wolfie
fighting in a war together which war you
ask all of them but I was also bummed
because there was a good post-credits
scene apparently that I missed this was
back in 2009 and I hadn't yet adjusted
to the fact that now we need to stay in
our seats for 15 extra minutes to see
what's next God you ever shut up Bill
one of the best examples of this very
post-credit scene phenomenon would be at
the end of Civil War where I did stay
and we got our first glimpse of wakanda
black panther picked up the action a
couple years later and plays out as one
long memorable moment the emotional
weight not to mention the great battles
Black Panther and killmonger going at it
it's among the most powerful in all the
MCU and the fight with Winston Duke's
umbaku is great as well Leticia writes
shuri isn't just attack Wiz she also
brings a sense of humor deep inside
t'challa to the Forefront
o and when Black Panther and the dorm
Elijah are in sync like in the casino
brawl that's a formidable opponent for
anyone or anything please stop the movie
called Logan much like the movie called
Black Panther elevated the genre to new
heights in terms of Storytelling acting
and the emotions that a comic book film
could conjure inside of us Wolverine
battling the reavers on his own time
clock and annoying kids in his limo all
factor in but it's also the tender
scenes between him and x-24 or Professor
X for that matter that helped the film
stand out and if we count all the chills
we got in end game seeing black panther
return to kick more ass we should also
point out how perfectly delivered the
one line that Wolverine has in first
class is this is a family show so let's
just say he's not too keen on joining
Charles and Eric with whatever the hell
they're doing just yet all told
Wolverine has too much history to ignore
in this round but I will award each
fella some quick bonus points the scene
in Black Panther where t'challa gets to
chat with his fallen father tugs at the
heartstrings and it shows the elite
acting company that Bozeman will always
be among amongst Jackman is tremendous
as Wolverine and he can sneakily deliver
comedy such as his very matter-of-fact
answer when Iceman's parents ask about
what he teaches at the school art the
art teacher takes round three and
suddenly Wolverine goes up 2-1 over
Black Panther and a boy round four
Legacy and now we arrive at one of the
tougher rounds in the history of this
show to judge both characters have meant
so much to so many people for so many
different reasons sure they're badasses
and one can go Rogue and let us tag
along the other can lead a nation and
keep us captivated But ultimately who
has forged the better Legacy black
panther let Wolverine get a 15-year Head
Start but when t'challa first appeared
it was much more overdue than just by a
decade in change I can't even comprehend
the feeling that black folks had finally
getting to see themselves represented in
glorious superhero form for the very
first time in a prominent role in the
MCU blade had set the tone way back
Terence Howard and Don Cheadle have been
valued editions but black panther was
pure superhero magic to everyone
regardless of race or any other Factor
but it was just special how important
that movie was and to be released during
Black History Month and for it to make
the kind of history at the box office
that it did it was truly a Cornerstone
moment in cinematic history Wolverine
wouldn't have near the cultural
relevance of a black panther but even
back in 2000 you could feel the
crossover appeal potential for the
character that Hugh Jackman was
embodying it wasn't just the comic book
nuts were pleased with this performance
from a guy way too tall to play the five
foot nothing version that we see in the
panels of Marvel it was the sense that
you could have never heard of the X-Men
but yet feel a connection to this guy
because he just felt real he wasn't a
classic hero like Batman didn't have the
clean-cut pedigree of Superman this
fellow was fueled by rage and Vengeance
and didn't always play nice with others
even the like-minded ones we saw a hero
not always making heroic decisions he
was more Han Solo than W do right and it
made Wolverine Stand Out ultimately the
legacy of Wolverine may be how tough to
follow Hugh Jackman will be in that role
rumors have about it for close to a
decade as to who that next one might be
and a handful of Hollywood a-lister
names have been bandied about at some
point the franchise has had multiple
opportunities to hit the reset button
but the appeal of Jackman was so
prevalent that you just can't resist
giving him as many swings as that guy
wants sadly we'll never get to see
Chadwick Boseman lead another black
panther film but much like the mythology
of that title the hero tradition will
continue on with someone the trailers
for the sequel wakanda forever know
exactly what they're doing giving us
plenty of action footage to speculate on
who might be in that suit but they also
set up our expectation that this will be
an emotional passing of the torch the
film sets out to honor both t'challa and
Bozeman and when it does given the fact
that Ryan cougar is a wonderful
filmmaker I don't anticipate there being
a dry eye in that house as crucial as
Wolverine was back in 2000 for setting
the standard on how complex a hero could
be we also were about to meet Toby
Maguire's Spider-Man trilogy then Tony
Stark and his Myriad issues Landing in
2008 but black panther even as inundated
as we already were in the end see you by
the time his movie came out in 2018 it
just hit different it hit deeper and it
was never about one aspect it was part
Bozeman's Talent part Legacy and a huge
payoff for everyone who is waiting to
see someone else be able to live the
superhero life both Black Panther and
Wolverine opened doors when they debuted
but only t'challa kicked down other
doors in the process and the world not
just the MCU was better for It Black
Panther wins the Legacy round and ties
the ball game 2-2 this is your last
chance and now it's time for the Wild
Card round by the power vested in me
I've actually said that before at
weddings no really I'm Mark Ellis your
host who many of you assumed to have the
intelligence of a toddler and the
personality of a shy Turtle Emma man of
the clock I went online One Click Boom
now I have magic powers but no this
round isn't about the many Powers
abilities and cool costume accoutrement
I have Nay it's a showdown between
Wolverine and Black Panther in the round
that will determine the match both dudes
have lots going for them in terms of
features Wolverine leans in his
incredible regenerative abilities in
virtually every film and the infusion of
adamantium into his skeleton has
increased several of his already
superpowers even more so but he still
feels the pain from injuries during and
even after the healing process has been
completed hence why we see Wolfie
starting to look his age in Logan
taking on the mantle of the Black
Panther meant getting in touch with his
spiritual side in the comics this helps
him defend against mystical spells that
might be cast towards him or his land
and he can also manifest certain
qualities from nature and the spirit
world as needed but he and Wolverine
also have a natural athletic prowess
that speaks to their awesome nicknames
they can move fight and recover with
greater speed and dexterity than us
normies and Wolverine additionally has
the ability to smell out enemies coming
from a much greater distance than old
regular Joes that's one thing him and my
dog actually have in common but black
panther also has that suit full of
hidden goodies that can distract a foe
or help carve a number of sharp
incisions into them speaking of claws
Wolverine has the most famous set this
side of Freddy Krueger they were already
a pretty dense bone when they teamed up
with adamantium during another
experimental trial for this weapon well
trust me you do not want to be on the
receiving end of those puppies
if we got more philosophical just for a
sec Black Panther and Wolverine have
very different outlooks on how to go
about being a hero t'challa wants to
carry on Howard Legacy and keep his
people his land and the tech and
resources therein secret and safe Logan
just wants all that stuff for himself
Logan we won't hit the team yeah good
luck with that it's not necessarily
being selfish it's just that he's always
been a loner and can't really open up to
a lot of folks he'd make a great
stand-up comedian both have powers that
could help neutralize each other if it
ever came down to a good guy brawl I'm
not sure who I'd pick as they both have
plenty of friends t'challa has all of
wakanda Wolverine's got the X-Men I
think wakanda would fight harder for
their guy but those tribes do have some
internal strife occasionally the X-Men I
don't know they've even called Wolverine
a friend all the time but let's be
honest they know they need him to be
upright both to defend against the evil
and to you know keep this franchise
making money just telling the truth if
all these powers and abilities end up
being a tie then it makes my call for
this match even tougher black panther as
a film had the ability to unite so many
folks including newcomers who could
finally feel represented on screen in an
exciting new way there may never be
another cultural moment in comic book
films akin to what we saw in 2018 with
black panther it was just that powerful
and having Chadwick Boseman perfectly
nailed the performance by becoming not
just a superhero but a fully fleshed out
character was awe-inspiring there is
little chance we'll see something become
bigger than that in a film anytime soon
and if we do it's not going to be a
wolverine flick conversation's over but
as far as playing and inhabiting a
character Hugh Jackman got an
opportunity and ran with it longer than
anyone else had in history seriously he
said a Guinness world record for the
longest time playing a single comic book
character in movies some feel that Mark
was broken when Toby Maguire and Willem
Dafoe returned to their roles in
Spider-Man no way home or you could make
a case for Michael Keaton as Batman if
he ever comes back and you know we
actually get to see the footage come on
y'all make Batgirl happen but I'd still
go with Wolverine because Hugh Jackman
has consistently carried that mantle
since day one never acted fatigued by it
rather it seems to energize him to this
very day without pitch and Hauling him
into just one roll in terms of
individual films black panther is up
there with Superman 78 Batman 89 Logan
end game The Dark Knight and maybe
surpasses all of them in terms of the
greatest comic book film ever but is one
person becoming a beloved character I
have to go with the length of time and
commitment to crap that Hugh Jackman
poured into Wolverine there's hopefully
many more Adventures for both characters
to come as we all honor Chadwick Boseman
with each New Black Panther outing but
for this match and all it entails
Wolverine gets the win in the Wild Card
round and thus takes the match okay
thank you both enough for everything
keep in mind that this is all just a fun
way to celebrate two great actors
legitimizing a pair of the coolest
superheroes ever so whoever you think
was the real winner today that is the
right answer I'm just one guy looking at
numbers in history and factoring in
opinions Wolverine got it today I could
wake up tomorrow and say black panther
should have gotten it hit me up on
social media with your take at Mark
Ellis live and stay tuned right here at
Rotten Tomatoes for all the latest in
the world of TV movies and all the
superhero stuff in between thanks for
watching versus and in the words of
Wolfie I really actually do think enough
said
[Applause]
foreign